if you need to reach out to complete
strangers to have them help you grow
your business I'm going to share with
you a quick story today about one recent
example that I went through and I think
you could model to help you build your
business hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I've
always been a huge Howard Schultz fan
he's the guy behind Starbucks I love
what he stands for I love his messaging
I love what he talks about an
entrepreneurship and dreaming big and
encouraging people to follow their
dreams and not listen to the naysayers
he's got a lot of great videos we
featured some on this channel and so
when he came up with this book I
discovered it not too long ago called
onward I had to read it and when I was
flipping through something interesting
came up on page 4 you don't forget
through it very long where it says
there's one word that comes to mind when
I think about our company and our people
that word is love now right away that
blew my mind because I've been an
advocate of finding one word that you
stand for that your business stands for
and and inject it right stand for
something with your company
- believe and I've been helping other
entrepreneurs do it I'm writing my own
book on this process and I thought
Howard Schultz you know one of these
guys that I really look up to Howard
Schultz he is all about one word as well
I have to find a way to get in touch now
usually when I want to reach out to
somebody my first step is to look at my
network does anybody know Howard Schultz
that I know and he co-wrote this with
Joanne Gordon and you know did does
anybody know jooheon's anybody know this
he Paul neither reach out I got to get
in touch and nobody in my network knew
either Howard or Joanne so my first
option was out of luck the next thing I
always do is try to reach out on social
media my favorite two channels are
Twitter and YouTube and what I'll often
do is find them on Twitter YouTube
follow them start to engage with their
stuff comment on it share it and my goal
is to get them to know me right to add
value to give them something in return
before I ever ask for anything and when
I do message them they know who I am
they recognize my face because I've been
tweeting and sharing all their stuff the
problem here again though was neither
Howard or Joanne were on Twitter or
YouTube so my
usual strategies of trying to use my
connections and trying to reach out on
social media they weren't working for me
this time around and I really wanted to
connect and and it just I sat on it and
was sitting there in my inbox as a to-do
list for weeks and weeks and weeks and
like you know what one day it was an
evening there like 6 o'clock at night I
just decided I'm gonna write Joanne she
had a website you had a contact I'm just
gonna write to her and I'm gonna I'm
gonna pour my heart out I'm gonna I'm
gonna grid a authentic email asking what
I was asking and I was reluctant at the
start because I hate being the guy who
asked for stuff right I hate being the
guy who doesn't provide any value and
it's just writing to somebody asking
them for something and so I wanted to
express that in an email and make her
realize that I'm a genuine guy I love to
help others anyway and so I'm gonna read
you the email that I sent and I might be
able to use it as a template for you
guys we're trying to reach out to people
who you need to reach out to hi Joanne
this might be one of the stranger emails
you receive today my name is Evan
Carmichael I have a popular website that
has over 20 million people visited and a
rapidly growing YouTube channel with
over 5 million views I also have a radio
show that reaches almost 600 station
across America and Forbes named me one
of the top 40 social marketing talents
so my goal here at the start was to lead
with something curious interesting this
might be one of the stranger emails that
you received today to make her want to
read more and then I also included a
little bit about me that I'm not just
some guy off the street that I have some
authority and and hopefully I'm somebody
worth listening to continuing on I said
I'm doing an interview series and I'm
writing the book with a major publisher
called one word where I'm discussing
finding one word that you believe in to
your core and profiling famous
entrepreneurs who build businesses
around their one word after reading on
word amazing amazing amazing book did I
say amazing
I noticed these lines there's one word
that comes to mind when I think about
our company and our people that word is
love I love suburbs because everything
we do is steeped in humanity Howard
Schultz is one of my favorite
entrepreneurs of all time because he has
an important mission and it really
stands for something powerful it's
inspiring and I wish every entrepreneur
knew about his stories they could model
him and learn from him so here now
trying to show that I've read your book
I really
you it I love it it has great content
I'm sending something really personal
something from the heart not just some
boilerplate you know template content
that I'm asking for something right I
really want to show that I really care
about what she's created and a really
value her opinion then I wrote my
question to you is if there is any way
you'd be able to set up an introduction
to him to see if I could interview him
from my series on my book I know it's a
huge ask especially coming for a
complete stranger and it's totally
outside my usual style doing things but
I don't have any other connections at
the moment I don't know that I have much
to offer you in return apart from a
heartfelt thank-you and lifelong
gratitude I'd be happy to help parallel
projects that you're working on to my
audience I don't know if that's
important to you and I really hate the
idea of just trading favors I guess the
bottom line is I would really appreciate
introduction and I would be in lifelong
debt to you happy to help whenever I can
whenever you need because you did
something lovely for a complete stranger
who's trying to do something important
and powerful for the world I'm happy to
provide you more information on me the
series the book thank you so much for
consideration in your time I sincerely
appreciated Cheers Evan believe so I got
to my ask what I really wanted was a
potential introduction to Howard Schultz
obviously she knew him because she
co-wrote the book with him and I really
wanted her to feel like this is
something that was important to me you
know it's something that I really valued
her help with it's not just hey hooked
me up to Howard Schultz please and I
really wanted her to feel like if there
was anything I could do to help her
just let me know you know I didn't want
it to feel like hey I'll help you so you
helped me I really wanted to help her if
there was any way I could do it and and
I would be in lifelong gratitude to her
and she's helping a complete stranger
out and so I felt like this is
everything I got you know this is this
is me pouring it onto an email putting
my heart out there and hopefully I get a
positive response
now she wrote back that same evening
with this message hi Evan thank you for
such a heartfelt and sincere email I'm
touched at the book resonated with you
the way it did I know you can never say
amazing enough to an author happy face
I've shared your email with the powers
that be at Starbucks who handle requests
such as yours for Howard someone will
reach out to you and hopefully we'll get
your meeting Thanks
for emailing and congratulations on your
success best Jo n now that email made my
night you know that came in just before
midnight I opened it up and I showed my
wife Lacroix she saw the email she
responded she said it send it off to
Howard so amazing and and regardless of
if it happens or not regardless of if
the PR people reach out to me it hasn't
happened yet but but even if it never
happens the fact that Joanne was willing
to do that speaks a lot to her character
in her heart and what a wonderful person
she is even though I've never met her
just had this brief email discussion
with her but for those of you who are
trying to reach out to somebody who you
feel like you really need to make this
connection to grow your business you
know you could start with your personal
connections you can start with the
social media and if it doesn't work then
just be passionate that's the difference
right be heartfelt be passionate do your
research
let the person know that you really
value this time and you really want to
make that connection and if you are
putting your heart on your sleep like
that you're making it really really
really difficult for somebody to say no
to you and when you are genuine people
will want to work with you so that's my
story hopefully that helped you and I'll
share the contents of my email in the
description so you can have a template
if you want to kind of look at and model
and follow and that's it for today thank
you guys so much for watching a special
thank you to Joanne for responding and
being such an amazing human being and
for those of you watching I'd love to
know who you've reached out to or how
you've reached out to complete strangers
or if you have a fear of reaching out to
complete strangers leave a comment below
I'd love to see the discussion get going
I'm going to join in that conversation
as well thank you everybody so much for
watching if you like this video you want
to see more don't forget to subscribe to
the newsletter into the channel and what
do you think about my new artwork up on
the wall believe